should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
a real underlying question for me is why
didn't I just keep my mouth shut and
ultimately I think what happened was
through the recurrent investigations
that I was put through
I think that I became somewhat
morally
protected I felt like
the words of Esther 4 14 have you
considered you're in the position you're
in for such a time as this they really
rang true in my life I had access to
information people didn't have I
absolutely was doing my responsible
duties I was doing my due diligence I
was reading two three four hours a day
trying to keep current on all the issues
going on with the Minnesota Senate the
covet pandemic worldwide and trying to
hold my family together as well and in
the end I felt that I was absolutely
entrusted to be a voice to watch out for
those encroachments on our liberties to
say no we're not going to let government
expand willy-nilly just because they can
[Music]
Dr Scott Jensen
has practiced Family Medicine in Carver
County Minnesota for 35 years
this is also where he and his wife Mary
a small animal veterinarian
raised their three children
Christie an anesthesiologist Matt and a
state attorney and Jackie a family
doctor Dr Jensen also served in the
Minnesota Senate from 2017 to 2021 and
he was vice chair
of the Health and Human Services
committee good morning Dr Jensen
good morning Nate it's good to see you
Dr Peterson
good to see you I understand it's three
in the morning there I'm in Rome right
now so I guess this is the best we could
do in terms of scheduling so thank you
very much for agreeing to do this today
well you're very welcome I'm actually in
Chaska Minnesota and I'm right across
the street from the Catholic church so
we do have something in common
right right right your your symbolically
near Rome
amen
yeah okay so let's let's get into this
let's first of all start by letting
everybody know who you are and then
we'll move into what has happened to you
uh right from the beginning it in
relationship to your
uh entanglement let's say with what's
supposed to be your professional
governing body and it's supposed to be
professional governing body and so let
it who
let's let's walk through the details of
your employment first so
well Dr Peterson again thank you for
having me on I'm a small town kid I grew
up in southern Minnesota in a town named
Sleepy Eye
pretty typical upbringing it takes a
village to raise a child my mom was my
best friend my dad was my hero I had
three brothers and a sister I went to
the public school and graduated as
valedictorian of the class but that's
not such a big deal when you only have
65 kids in your class I went to the
University of Minnesota
and was going to be an orthodontist but
when I got into dental school I found
out that I did not have a love affair
with teeth so I left dental school and
went to the Seminary for a year and at
the time I'd been dating this really
wonderful lady and so that year in the
Seminary I made the decision to ask her
to marry me and we've been together for
45 years I also made the decision to go
into medicine so I went into family
practice went to the University of
Minnesota med school did my residency
and my wife is a veterinarian we have
three wonderful children our two
daughters are Physicians we're not
exactly sure what happened to our son
but he's an attorney but we love him
just as much
and uh we well there's four Physicians
probably need one attorney he says that
he has to keep the rest of us out of
trouble
so that's right that's where we're
landing on there
so then um I've been practicing medicine
for about 37 years in the Chaska
Watertown area
and about eight years ago I was
encouraged to run for the senate in
Minnesota this had not been one of my
bucket list items so I was leery about
it but after a couple of months of being
recruited I made the decision to run for
Senate I ended up winning and receiving
more votes than any other Republican
Senate candidate in Minnesota
during the first three years of my
Senate career
I have to confess that I was
disillusioned with the process I was
surprised at how easily gridlock was the
order of the day
I felt like
really genuine fired up intellectual
curiosity just wasn't a part of the
equation and that frustrated me quite a
bit at the same time my wife was having
some health issues and she was going to
have a need for multiple surgeries so I
made the decision to not run for
re-election
a few months later covet hit
covet hit hard it hit everybody hard
but I think I like so many other people
suffered from certain personality traits
I'm somewhat skeptical and medical
school taught us to be skeptical I've
always been sort of addicted to context
and I've always thought that
if we don't have the context of what
we're seeing we can't really digest what
we're dealing with and I had access to
more information than many people did
because I was vice chair of the Health
and Human Services Committee in the
Senate and so I was aware of much of
what was going on
and then in the early days of April of
2020 when I received a
an email from the Department of Health
with a link to the CDC advising me as a
physician that they were going to adjust
the way death certificates were
completed
and
without meaning to be any kind of grand
whistleblower I ended up making comment
about this on a local TV program that
I'd been on the news for and that
traveled what did it just what did a
just death certificates mean
basically in the Minnesota Department of
Health communication to the Physicians
they said if you believe that covid-19
may have contributed to the cause of
death you can go ahead and put it down
as the cause of death and that's not
right the CDs wow the CD the CDC for
decades has said that our job as
Physicians when we complete a death
certificate is to try to identify the
initiating event
that started the process of demise for
the patient so for example if I have a
heart attack
tomorrow and a month later I have
congestive heart failure and we find
that the heart attack was so substantial
that I've lost the ability to
effectively pump blood and we learned
that I'm not a candidate for transplant
and there's no remedies for my situation
and over time I falter and become more
and more frail and perhaps I go on
hospice knowing that I have end-stage
heart disease
if on my last 48 hours of life on Earth
I get exposed to covet 19.
without ever being tested or even having
any symptoms of it
when I die
I died
of a heart attack
the underlying cause of death would be
coronary artery disease and that led to
a heart attack which led to congestive
heart failure but it should not say that
covid-19 was the cause of my death we
were being encouraged to go ahead and
they said in this document if you think
that covid-19 was a contributing
condition you can put it down as a cause
of death and I said no
there's a box too on a death certificate
called contributing conditions that's
where you put contributing conditions if
it's emphysema if it's asthma
influenza we put it in the contributing
conditions box we were being told with
this disease we could put it as a cause
of death I raised a Ruckus and said this
isn't right
I did not get any response from the
Department of Health instead I was asked
to be on numerous National TV programs I
was asked to be on the Ingram angle and
subsequently Rush Limbaugh came to my
defense and we had Tucker Carlson show
on inviting me but the bottom line is
this was April of 2020.
and in June of 2020 I received a letter
with red letters stamped confidential
from the board of Medical Practice
advising me that for the first time in
my career my license was under
investigation
so there the CDC suggests to Physicians
that they alter their their death
notification practice in the case of
covid
listing um as you pointed out
contributory cause of death
as a primary cause of death and so this
begs three questions
um the CDC
re-construction of the guidelines first
of all why in the world would they do
that in the case of covid
second who would do that and third what
does that do to the reliability of the
death uh statistics that are used to
calculate the virality and lethality of
covid
those three questions are frankly the
critical ones and they're interrelated
the first one is to why the CDC would do
this
it felt to me like there was a movement
or a strong motivation to
if you will
elevate
the seriousness of the coveted pandemic
I think that it was already elevated
substantially and that troubled me
deeply I raised that question early on I
said I think we're making an epidemic of
fear
as much as we're responding from a
public policy perspective so when the
CDC did that it felt to me like they
wanted to ensure that they got our
attention and that there would be
numbers to support that
as to who would do that I think later on
we found out that some of the major
characters were people that were indeed
in charge of the public policies that
were going to govern the world if you
will for the next three years
specifically you had people like Dr Tony
fauci you had Dr Deborah Burks you had
some of these people who had if you will
high-placed positions from which to
speak they literally had absolute power
and I'm a big believer that absolute
power corrupts
and I think the third question is
probably the most important one Dr
Peterson
what impact would this have on the
reliability of our federal registrar in
terms of cause of death for instance
every year in America the United States
we have approximately 650 000 people die
of heart disease we have approximately
six hundred thousand people die of
cancer
if those deaths are recorded instead of
cardiac causes and putting it down as
covid numerous things happen one is we
might get a false impression that we're
making Headway on heart disease when
we're really not you might see
pharmaceutical companies coming to the
fore saying see we told you if you take
our drugs if you prescribe our drugs put
more people on Lipitor we will reduce
the heart cause of deaths and that would
be not true that would be a Corruption
of the actual data there would be all
kinds of Nefarious opportunities for
people to grab a hold of corrupted data
and make a case for something that
wasn't real and when I raised that point
I didn't get a legitimate
discussion there was no robust
questioning it was you're spreading
conspiracy theories and you're having
the audacity to cause or to compare
covid to influenza and those were a
couple of the first so let me ask you
let me ask you a nasty question then
um to play The Devil's Advocate
so
we walked through your career and
really very very briefly your life and
it it's a real American fairy tale life
small town American fairy tale life and
so a skeptic would say especially a
skeptic who's arguing from the other
side let's say would say well
you you uh you missed the Limelight
there we go because you were no longer
involved in the political scene and you
got a little bit of attention because
you complained about a perfectly
reasonable request from the CDC to be
what would you say hyper careful in
relationship to the
lethality of kovid
then a bunch of right-wing
conspiratorialists like Rush Limbaugh
and Tucker Carlson rushed in and you got
some attention on the national stage and
that went to your head and so it was in
your best interest to cast aspersions on
the motivations of people who were only
trying to benefit public health and this
is on you which I presume is the tack
that the governing board of your
profession essentially took when they
came after you with this confidential
letter so how do you
what sort of soul-searching did you do
when this first came up and how do you
protect yourself against those sorts of
insinuations and allegations and even
doubts
that's a good question I think it's
important to look a little bit at the
Timeline it was in the summer of 2019
which was well in advance of the covet
pandemic that I had made the
announcement that I was done with
politics my wife's Health was in an
issue and she was going to have multiple
surgeries so I had already announced
that I was not running for re-election
so in 2020 when the covet hit
I was serving my last year as a senator
I was vice chair of the Health and Human
Services committee I carried a large
insulin Bill through and worked with
Democrats to get it done and Governor
walls signed that
at that point in my life I had made it
pretty clear that I was not interested
in being in the Limelight I was
interested in stepping away from
politics and being there for my family
my wife's Health was an issue but I'd
also been blessed with five
grandchildren within the span of about
two or three years and they were all
under the age of I believe four at the
time or perhaps even under three so it
was time for me to continue to practice
medicine take care of my wife and be a
grandpa and I was very content with that
so in terms of some in terms of some
underlying deep-seated desire for fame
and infamy I would say that
that's almost ridiculous because the
slings and arrows eye and the slings and
arrows I ended up taking uh were hurtful
I had never been in a situation right
well you also you also had some
Limelight politically speaking already
the fact that you'd you know run a
political campaign you've been out in
public I mean you had your a reasonable
share of public attention but you're
also interestingly well situated because
you are a physician of long-standing and
also you were a senator and was it Vice
chairman of the health services
committee
yes and the other thing so you'd think
that you would have demonstrated you'd
think that all of that would have
demonstrated your qualifications to
speak on such matters
Dr Peterson when I was a resident
I was named one of the 15 top residents
in the country through Amy Johnson award
program in the late 1990s I was awarded
a bush Fellowship to study leadership
computers and plastic surgery techniques
in 2016 I had been named the family
physician of the year in Minnesota
I've had a wonderful career
I feel at times a little bit like Jimmy
Stewart in It's a Wonderful Life there
was no reason for me to put all of that
at risk and put myself in a position
where people would ridicule me literally
monitor every word I said in order to
try to play that gotcha game and hit me
with something
it was tough on my wife during that that
last year in the Senate the first year
of the pandemic 2020. it was a painful
year I'm not going to deny it um we had
schisms within my own family we had
plenty of tears and and axed and
it would have been fun to not have to go
through that people have asked me they
said they said Dr Jensen
what was that like how did you know all
this was going to happen and I've told
people I didn't know quite frankly I
feel a little bit like Jonah in the Old
Testament where he was asked to do some
tough Duty in Nineveh and he said no
thanks I'm going to take a cruise on the
Mediterranean that's what I feel like
but then this whale got in the way
swallowed me up and spit me out on this
pathway of ridicule and if you will
focus on everything about my background
and it was tough to go through
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible Bible
printed on the Press of Johann Gover
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away
with at least a sense of that
when I spoke with Jay battacharya uh
recently he went through a similar
experience at Stanford very similar he's
an outstanding physician and uh an
extremely reputable person and he
expressed some extreme skepticism about
the covid hysteria and Stanford
basically turned its back on him and he
lost 35 pounds in three months and it
just about killed him I mean I've talked
to probably a hundred people now who've
been in the situation that you were in a
situation that I've been in a number of
times and
virtually all of them
were pushed to the limits of their
psychological and physical tolerance by
that process of cancellation and mobbing
and exclusion you know and some of the
people I know quite well who are as
stable of personalities as you'd ever
hope to encounter were driven right to
the edge of Madness by this insane mob
inspired persecution you know when I
actually think that the degree to which
that affects you
is proportionate
to some degree to your moral Integrity
in that a person who's highly
conscientious
and hard-working diligent
detail-oriented all of that
um is also
tends to be somewhat
guilt prone
in that any accusation of abdication of
Duty strikes a person like that to the
heart because they are in fact dutiful
now if you're incompetent and
unconscientious and parasitic in your
fundamental orientation towards others
and someone accuses you of not doing
your duty you don't ever you have never
regarded that as a necessity or a virtue
in the first place and so those
criticisms fall on deaf ears but if
you've been gone after after having
after having checked off all the proper
boxes let's say both practically and
morally then it can be incredibly
damaging and it also does produce this
internal Schism in family because of
course it's easy for people to think
well you know
if you or at least for people to fight
about the issue of well maybe it would
have been better had you just never said
anything rather than have having exposed
yourself and others within the family to
risk and
you know there is an argument to be had
about that because it's not obvious
but you should just shut the hell up and
keep on
struggling forward because you know
every bureaucracy and has its
inadequacies and you can't complain
about everything and when you finally
have to stand up and say something and
of course that is going to
cause tensions within families
especially if you're also under other
forms of stress by this time
had your wife recovered from her medical
trouble
Mary had gone through two surgeries and
then had a third surgery she'd had her
neck fused she'd had a new joint put in
and so she was recovering but while she
was recovering unfortunately a lot of
the conversations the two of us would
have at home while she's convalescing
seemed to always come back to covet 19.
so that was it was a challenge and
you're exactly right Dr Peterson
there was
a real underlying question for me is why
didn't I just keep my mouth shut and
ultimately I think what happened was
through the recurrent investigations
that I was put through
I think that I became somewhat
morally
protected I felt like
the words of Esther 4 14 have you
considered you're in the position you're
in for such a time as this they really
rang true in my life and I felt a little
bit like a Pit Bull with a pork chop in
my mouth and I wasn't going to let
anybody take that pork chop of Truth out
of my mouth I had access to information
people didn't have I absolutely was
doing my responsible duties I was doing
my due diligence I was reading two three
four hours a day trying to keep current
on all the issues going on with the
Minnesota Senate the covet pandemic
worldwide and trying to hold my family
together as well and in the end I felt
that I was absolutely entrusted to be a
voice to watch out for those
encroachments on our liberties to say no
we're not going to let government expand
willy-nilly just because they can and I
found myself getting
tenacious and I remember someone very
close to me said well why is it so
important to be right
and I said
I don't think it's about being right I
think it's about
being fearful of what I was seeing when
a rubber band is stretched Beyond its
capacity it never returns to its normal
shape and configuration that's what I'm
worried about with the United States
Canada Nations across the globe we've
seen something happen over a three-year
period that prior to those three years
most of us would say couldn't happen if
it had been put in a movie we would have
said someone's been watching too much
Grade B fiction but the bottom line it
was happening right in front of us and
we were stunned all right so you picked
up this letter it had red confidential
written over it and well so here's a
couple of questions about that damn
letter so the first is
you'd think that if and what's the
what's the precise name of the board
that sent you the letter and this is the
governing board of physicians in
Minnesota
this is the physician's regulatory
agency regarding licensure and it's
called the Minnesota Board of Medical
Practice the Minnesota Board Medical
Practice mbmp
more to bet the board of Medical
Practice okay so you get a letter from
the Minnesota Board of medical practice
now here's some mysteries about that
so the first mystery is
why in the world did they think that you
were going to be a credible Target I
mean look you you've got a stellar
reputation on the educational front and
you have a stellar reputation as a
physician as attested to by multiple
forms of achievement and recognition
plus you're you'd been a senator and so
you'd think that just procedurally the
people who were
sitting on this board
would have been wise enough to think
that
barring
self-evident
malfeasance you were probably someone
best left alone
so that's that's an interesting question
why they would actually
be clueless enough to Target you without
a smoking pistol
and so and then the next question is
what exactly did they claim in their
first attempt to discipline you
I think In fairness to the Minnesota
Board of Medical Practice individuals
who serve on that board
their Collective perception of what
they're to do is that their mission is
to investigate all complaints that come
forward
so in Minnesota you can go on the
Minnesota Board of Medical Practice
webpage
dribble out a complaint you have no
obligation to do any due diligence your
personality your
Vital Information about who you are will
remain anonymous the person you accuse
has no way of getting your name you will
be protected by anonymity you will not
be identified so it's relatively easy to
make a complaint you don't have to know
the person you're complaining about you
don't have to ever have received a
health care service from them but the
Minnesota Board of Medical Practice has
taken the position if there's a
complaint we'll investigate it so I
think right but that doesn't mean but in
in Canada tell me if it's the same in
the United States so it's exactly the
same situation that you just described
with regards to the regulating Board of
psychologists in Ontario anyone anywhere
in the world can submit a complaint for
any reason now the the
um Ontario Board of psychologists
College of psychologists is legally
obligated obliged to
to investigate every complaint which
means at least to consider the complaint
but they are not obligated to pursue the
investigation if they believe that the
complaint was frivolous or vexatious
and that's obviously a necessary
corollary when
the accuser is given the protections
that you just described which is that
there is no
pressure
incumbent upon them to even provide
documentation of the validity of their
complaint nor any requirement to have
had any even second person contact with
you
so it it may be the case that the board
members
felt that it was necessary for them to
consider the complaint but that does not
mean that it was necessary for them to
pursue you they decided to pursue you
and that doesn't follow logically from
the mere fact of the complaint
especially because you had practiced for
you said 37 years
without any complaints and also in an
obviously Stellar manner so there's
something more going on than the mere
proclivity of the Minnesota Minnesota
Board of Medical Practice members to do
their Duty
the Minnesota Board of Medical Practice
in their first investigation of me
pointed out that there had been
allegations that I had spread conspiracy
theories and I was providing Reckless
advice by comparing influenza to covet
which by the way is exactly what Dr
fauci and other leading speakers to the
narrative had done but I think the
pattern of behavior by the Minnesota
Board of Medical Practice attests to
your concerns Dr Jordan investigation
number one came at me with allegations
and I responded and received a letter it
was dismissed investigation 2 was
similar investigation three I was never
advised that there was a pending
investigation or that there were
allegations on the table I was simply
sent a letter by the Minnesota Board of
Medical Practice indicating oh by the
way
further allegations have come in they
have been dismissed I was not even
provided an opportunity to respond
investigation 4 went back to the first
two where they investigated me I
responded they dismissed them but
investigation number five is where it
gets interesting that came into being
okay so how many over how many over what
span of time
did these five investigations occur and
what did that mean in terms of
disruption to your practical life your
psychological State and the stability of
your family and your practice
the recurrent Minnesota Board of Medical
Practice investigations had a
devastating effect on my life while I
was in the Senate I felt hamstrung in my
personal life with my family I felt the
tension of differing viewpoints and as I
mentioned earlier people wondering
why is it so important to Scott Jensen
to be right when I was trying to
Advocate this isn't about being right
this is about something being terribly
wrong and that we cannot stand for it I
think this took place from June of 2020
to November of 2021
so that's a 15 to 18 month span of time
by then do you have any idea how many
allegations had been how many
allegations had were levied against you
that you had to respond individually to
and did you require legal counsel during
that entire time and what sort of
expense was that
the first four investigations I elected
to treat them like any regular family
doctor in the trenches would do so so I
read the allegations I responded to the
best of my ability I provided a
narrative explanation and I if you will
substantiated what I had to say with
articles and references so I did that
myself and that took literally hundreds
and hundreds of hours with each
investigation
the fifth investigation was put forth in
November of 2021 I was in the middle of
a Governor's election race I was one of
the leading candidates for the
Republican party and when I received
that investigation I was asked to
respond I did and that time was the
first time I was asked to provide
patient records that made me very
nervous violating patient
confidentiality so I was meticulous to
making certain that I de-identified
whatever I sent to them the other thing
that went with that was I had I made the
comment that I had used off-label
medications for
a handful of patients when asked to do
so in exceptional situations that really
seemed to change the nature of what was
going on at that point in time the board
of Medical Practice came back to me and
said okay we uh we're not sure that we
like where you're at here we asked for a
response you gave it to us
we've asked for more information as well
as patient records I submitted those
they said to me
we've received your records and that's
where it stopped and it stopped there
for a full year
all the other investigations and I want
to interject here for a minute for any
professionals medical professionals who
are listening
so one of the reasons that you do get a
lawyer very quickly in these
circumstances despite the expense
and uh the potential self-admission
perhaps that
or or the apparent the risk of apparent
admission of wrongdoing is that once an
investigation of this
sort commences
and you provide additional information
you open up a whole Rat's Nest of
additional potential avenues for
persecution
and so the first time the
College of psychologists came after me
the allegation they ended up nailing me
for this was back in 2017.
had virtually no resemblance to the
initial complaint it emerged as a
consequence of the need for Boards of
this type especially once they've
started to go down a particular Rabbit
Hole repeatedly to convince themselves
that they were justified in their
initial Inquisition by any means
whatsoever and so you know if you hadn't
done the wrong thing that you were
accused of well obviously the fact that
you'd been subject to four
investigations and multiple allegations
means that there's fire where there's
smoke and if we can't get you on
you know the fire on the left side of
the furnace will get you on the fire of
the right side of the furnace and a good
lawyer can help you provide minimal
information to Boards of Investigation
of that sort so that you're less likely
to lay out traps for yourself to step in
and then there's this issue of turning
over patient records you know by by the
end of my
Private Practice as a clinical
psychologist I was taking Atma at best
extraordinary minimal formal notes
because I knew that the probability that
I would be required at some point to
break
client confidentiality which might even
be more important for psychologists than
for Physicians although it's a toss-up
was virtually certain I could no longer
trust the inviability of my records to
inappropriate
um and paranoid
Board of governance screening and so
that's also an awful situation for
professionals to find themselves in
where the notes they take to ensure that
they're on top of their patients Health
can now be used as a means of
uh what would you say breaking the
Privacy walls surrounding the patient
which is the issue of critical
importance but also as endless fodder
for the continuation of Catholic
expensive punitive pointless and
punishing investigations especially
those that are politically motivated so
if this happens to you professionals who
are watching I would recommend and maybe
Dr Jensen can give his opinion on this
um
you should get yourself a lawyer damn
quick and then I've got a couple of
things to say about lawyers too is that
there is nothing more expensive than a
bad cheap lawyer so don't just get a
good lawyer get a or don't just get a
lawyer get a good lawyer because a good
lawyer who will be expensive is way less
expensive than a bad lawyer who makes
mistakes
so to your point Dr Peterson you're spot
on I think the first four investigations
I had to deal with that age-old question
do I stuff it to the side and try to
keep it private or do I come public with
it and I made the decision on the first
investigation at the recommendation of
several close friends and colleagues to
go public I was told that if I don't go
public with it literally
I would at some point in time be placed
on defense and I would never be able to
get around that they said you've got to
go on offense and that's what I did but
I did make I I probably made a mistake
with the first four investigations by
believing that if I was just responsive
thoughtful measured balanced that they
would dismiss these allegations which is
what happened the first four times
but at some point it changed and at that
point in time I think I had to give up
my normalcy bias I in my brain I thought
this can't be happening to me this
happens to other people you read about
it in the newspaper but this doesn't
happen to this small town kid from
Sleepy Eye Minnesota who's had the the
life of Jimmy Stewart and It's a
Wonderful Life and I kept I think I was
unable to really get my arms around that
this was happening to me in real life
real time and my license each each
investigation was more and more at risk
so with the fifth investigation when it
went on for a full year
then the election took place and I lost
and two months later I got a letter from
the board of Medical Practice providing
additional allegations based on exactly
what you said based on my response to
the fifth investigation including
patient records now I was being accused
of having handwriting that wasn't always
as legible as some reviewers would have
liked now I was being accused of well
you also did this and you did this and
by the way you did this and at that
point in time they said we're not we're
not accepting your written responses as
good we're now asking for a a notice of
conference that meant we're going to
meet with you and at that point in time
I said
I probably need to get an attorney and I
got a good attorney Out Mr Greg Joseph
is an attorney in Minnesota who's done a
lot of different kinds of law but has
really landed on understanding I think
the the nature
of that line
between professional conduct as it
relates to Patient Care versus Free
Speech now in in the United States I
don't believe that that line has been
determined with precision and that's one
of the remaining questions regarding my
situation
is recently we did have that
conference with the Minnesota Board of
Medical Practice
and I don't mean to get ahead of myself
but 18 allegations were being addressed
at one time they were from Soup To Nuts
it had to deal with masks it had to deal
with vaccines it had to deal with
comparisons of covet and influenza it
had to do with how we complete death
certificates how we remunerate hospitals
and doctors based on diagnosis codes
used it it ran the gamut but in the end
when the Minnesota Board of Medical
Practice says we're dismissing all of
the allegations at that point in time
we still don't know that critical
question where's the line between
professional conduct
and Free Speech because I would submit
that
Physicians get to be wrong
if we say on a Monday that this is what
we think perhaps we say something like
this
eggs have cholesterol you have high
cholesterol you should not eat eggs and
maybe four days later we come across
material that says gee eggs aren't so
bad so I tell my patient you know what
you can eat eggs now is that
misinformation perhaps is it
disinformation certainly not but the
bottom line is as a physician if I make
those comments in the exam room or if I
make those comments on stage at a
meeting a rally or perhaps a church
event
either way
I get to make those comments
okay well there's a more ominous element
to your story as well that
is still implicit in what we've
discussed so I'm going to
pull some of that out now now
you have been in the Senate and you
decided to pull out of the political
life but now you're running for governor
and while you're running for governor
these investigations are happening so
the first thing we should clear up for
everyone is that given that you had
decided to make an exit from the
political stage why did you decide to
return the next issue is were you
credible as a candidate for governor and
then the third question is
why the hell did the Minnesota
Board of Medical Practice presume that
it was
appropriate ethically
to conduct an investigation into the
conduct of a physician in the middle of
a political campaign because if you
can't see how that raises evil specters
of possibility you're not thinking
because what it means is that
the investigative process which puts all
the power in the hands of the accuser
can obviously be weaponized for
political purposes now it has it is
being and it has been in many cases and
that's going to get much worse before it
gets better but in your situation it's
particularly egregious because you were
a physician with a with an actual
credible political career and you were
running for the highest office in your
state
so what do you think about the fact that
the investigations
ramped up while you were running for
governor
what do you think that implies
for the stability and sanctity of the
political process and uh what effect do
you think the investigations into your
conduct and the public element of that
had on the outcome of the gubernatorial
race
2020 my last year in the Senate was
obviously the first year of the covet
pandemic
the pandemic and the public policies
that came with it
really were like this
powerful magnetic pull for me to not
leave the political if you will
field
I had
thousands of people reach out to me and
say Dr Jensen you've been a courageous
voice offering hope and reasonable
analysis of what's going on you've been
deeply embedded in context you've been a
skeptic you've accessed information
you've done your due diligence you've
taken seriously that you've been
entrusted with a voice to speak for
thousands and thousands of minnesotans
and people across the globe
that collectively is what really pulled
me into the race I think again I'm a
faith-based individual and the words of
Esther 4 14 for such a time as this
joined with the words of Hebrews 4 14
hold fast to the beliefs you profess
just did not seem to give me an out from
politics so I stepped into that arena
with my wife's blessing
was I a credible candidate
we accomplished more as a Conservative
candidate running in Minnesota than had
been accomplished in decades in some
situations ever we received more votes
than any Republican governor candidate
has ever received in Minnesota we raised
more money than any Republican Governor
has Ever Raised
in The Campaign Committee itself we had
over a hundred thousand people join our
email team we had 40 000 unique
donations we had approximately the same
percentage of Voters uh in the election
that Governor Tim polenti had in 2002
when he won we went against six other
candidates and prevailed in getting the
endorsement and then going to the
general election so from that
perspective we created a movement and
that movement was born of energy
conviction and Americans everyday
Americans that were horrifically
concerned about what is going on in our
world
so then the question is okay you've got
the Minnesota Board of Medical Practice
holding this
gray cloud over his head over the
campaign for literally the majority of
the campaign it had a devastating effect
I knew that everywhere I went I was
being tracked and recorded I knew every
word I said didn't just enter the
political speech it was going to be
filed and indexed and forwarded to the
Minnesota Board of Medical Practice
there was no relief from the Minnesota
Board of medical practice I reached out
to them in 2022 asking a question I
don't want to do something that's not up
to the standard of care if I prescribe
certain off-label drugs is that
problematic for you or not is that the
standard of care or not and I was given
a short answer from an administrative
staffer that said we don't create the
standard of care we can't tell you that
but if you do it and we get a complaint
we're going to investigate you they were
basically saying you want to know the
standard you want to know what this yeah
you want to know what the standard of
care is we're not telling you but if if
someone says you you didn't meet the
standard care were coming after you for
that the rest was a death standard of
Terror for these investigative boards is
uh
well we don't really know what we're
doing but we'll sure whack you if we
have any suspicions that you do
something wrong post Hawk I mean I've
had exactly the same experience with the
College of psychologists in Ontario
trying to get them to clarify their
policies around
um certification of of new practicing
psychologists for example and there
isn't a chance in the world that they'll
clarify their stance a priority this is
part of the reason you need a lawyer
when they come after you it's because
then it's not as if the standards are
well defined and it's certainly not as
if the practitioners on these boards are
sufficiently credible either
professionally or ethically to be doing
what they're doing the rules are
basically
um watch yourself and if you make a
mistake look the hell out and the
mistakes are defined after the ACT and
so so in that I'm I'm
stressing that for the professionals who
are listening is do not make the mistake
that Dr Jensen made of assuming that you
are dealing with a process that's going
to treat you reasonably
that is not the situation you're in
you're in a little bit of Kafka hell and
you'll be lucky if you escape from it
with your skin intact and so you can
dispense with any
niceties about your presumption that
this is going to be mere rational
discourse between merely rational people
if you're innocent and you have had a
stellar reputation and you're being
investigated for fundamentally political
reasons you're way outside the rubric of
anything that you might have regarded as
Jimmy Stewart nor Melody and the faster
you realize the that the easier it's
going to be for you
well said I think that without question
that tendency for me to say this can't
be happening that power of what is my
bias towards what's normal sort of
dictated my behavior until it didn't and
it was the fifth investigation no that's
a trauma response say just I you may
know this as a physician uh one of the
Hallmarks of
traumatic experience is the sense of
derealization that accompanies the
experience and derealization is the
recurrent sense he partly thought partly
perception that
there's no way this can be happening in
fact
the long the more intense that sense and
the longer its duration
the better the chance that post-event
there will be post-traumatic symptoms
that makes a lot of sense it does and I
honestly think that while perhaps Scott
Jensen was a microcosm of that
phenomenon occurring I think that from a
population standpoint on a macro level
we're seeing the same thing we're seeing
a derealization for Americans across the
the land saying well no that couldn't be
happening I mean we're seeing it with
Physicians I think Physicians over the
last three months have come out and said
to me Dr Jensen we feel so bad that we
haven't stood with you more strongly we
we should have been there for you but we
were scared for our jobs we were scared
for our livelihoods we knew that there
would be hell to pay and so I think
there's been a lot of that where you
literally have to dispense with your own
strong internal sense of what's normal
what's going to happen What would
reasonable people do and as you said
you've got to say all bets are off this
is a different place than I've ever been
before I'm not going to be able to do it
I'm not going to be able to navigate my
way through it by simply being
reasonable providing resources and
justification for what I was thinking
because that isn't going to carry the
day one of the things my attorney shared
with me now Greg Joseph Dr Peterson was
when we first met and this was to deal
with the fifth and the sixth
investigations he said Scott you didn't
hire me to be a yes man and I'm not
going to be I'm going to tell you what
you've been doing and I'm going to tell
you why it was wrong
and I was all ears and he said Scott
you're trying to make a perfect snowball
you're in a snowball fight and you're
trying to make the perfect snowball so
that you can win the snowball fight but
let me tell you two things one there
should be no snowball fight two there is
no perfect snowball you're not gonna
find the perfect article that's going to
convince the medical board that ah Dr
Jensen was sane and reasonable and
rational and right you're not going to
find that snowball so quit trying to
make it we should not be in this
snowball fight and we're going to tell
the Minnesota Board of Medical Practice
exactly that they don't have
jurisdiction over your speech
yeah yeah well that's good it does sound
like you got a good lawyer and I mean
one of the advantages and this is also
for the professionals who are listening
if you're an agreeable person
and that means you're fundamentally
compassionate and caring you don't like
conflict you like to put other people at
ease you're you're likely to go along to
get along well that might have been one
of the reasons that you entered
especially family medicine because
that's a branch of the profession that
tends to attract caring people now the
problem with being a caring person is
that
of that sort an agreeable person is that
you don't like conflict you're going to
always assume the best of others and
it's going to be difficult for you to
say no when you need to say no and what
no means by the way just so that
everyone who is listening is clear know
when you say it to someone means
if you don't stop doing that
something you do not like we will happen
to you with 100 certainty
that's what no means if you dare utter
it and so if you're an agreeable person
that's difficult and so if you're an
agreeable physician and you want people
to like you and you don't like conflict
and you're caring you need a
disagreeable lawyer
because a disagreeable lawyer has been
through this sort of thing many many
times and has the thick skin for it but
is also perfectly capable willing and
might even enjoy saying no when the
circumstances demand it and a good
litigator in particular litigators tend
to be quite disagreeable but um a
defense attorney can and attorneys in
general tend to be relatively
disagreeable especially if they're
effective so there are there's there's
definitely a Time
when you need someone
of the temperament that your lawyer
appears to be and it's useful to develop
that side of your character too that
part that can bite back when when bitten
you know not to
not more than necessary but certainly
not less than necessary
and so so what you have to dispense with
your presumption that you're in a
territory where rationality prevails and
you have to dispense with the
presumption that the people who are
coming after you or the forces that are
arrayed against you are of this sort
that's aiming up let's say okay so you
have Physicians now Physicians are what
coming to you behind the scenes and
saying that they wish they would support
you or these friends these are
colleagues and did did anybody actually
speak out from the medical community
in in your support
the great the great majority of the
voices of the medical community who were
opposed to me I was roundly criticized
there were ad hot groups of Physicians
getting together holding press
conferences ridiculing me the Minnesota
Medical Association has been not not
friendly to to my position but quietly
behind the scenes Physicians have
reached out to me and these are not
friends these are colleagues many of
whom I've never met I've received
numerous letters even in the last two
weeks from Physicians saying
we've been watching from afar we have
got to stay quiet we don't dare come out
but we so appreciate what you've done we
respect your character your integrity
the thoughtful measured manner in which
you've dealt with these slings and
arrows and we want you to know we
appreciate it and respect it oftentimes
within the notes there's almost an
underlying sense of confession almost a
an effort to
seek Absolution and I've oftentimes
responded to my colleagues and said I
get where you're at
I was in a different place I'm not young
I'm 68. I think these partisan activists
who you who decided to weaponize the
Minnesota Board of Medical Practice to
shut me up they didn't know me they may
have seen me as that person who was
always going to be approval seeking and
that but I think I do have the ability
perhaps I'm a little slow on the draw
but I do have the ability to say no
that's the Line in the Sand we'll go no
further and I did do that and I think
when I did that I did it in part because
I have
a shield of success in my career I'm 68.
I'm not dependent on their approval nor
am I dependent on the Minnesota Board of
medical practice for my rhizon de TOA my
reason for being I know exactly why I'm
here and that's not going to stop or
change I'm not going to Flinch and I so
I've I found it rewarding to have so
many colleagues nurses First Responders
reach out and say hey Doc thanks
appreciate it very much would have loved
to have been there standing right by
your side but I just couldn't do it and
I get that
so this okay so this fifth investigation
is occurring while you're running for
governor and you think it had a
devastating effect well it had
devastating effect on you as part and
parcel of this ongoing process
do you think it had a determining effect
on the election
that's an interesting question whether
or not
the investigation had not been going on
let me say that again
I think
the deep-seated nature of being
investigated by the Minnesota Board of
medical practice was utilized by my
opponents repeatedly I was accused of
participating in the big lie by some
Journal nationally this was used against
me over and over again and it forced me
to take positions on issues in a way
that
I would have liked to have not had to it
made me in some situations go farther
right in order to convince
a certain group of people that know I'm
not some whack job I'm a credible
thoughtful physician who's had a
wonderful career and you should ignore
these slings and arrows last night I got
an email just before
midnight that was from a journalist
who's going to be interviewing me and
she said what do you think about these
kinds of documents that are circulating
on social media that just denigrate your
character and so I looked at some of the
documents and there's a two-page index
document
totally eviscerating me saying that this
is a quack doctor and it's from the the
opposing party and it was boom boom boom
boom boom and this was used during the
campaign and some of the substance of it
did relate back to the fact that I was
being investigated by the Minnesota
Board of Medical Practice on some of
these same issues so did it have a
determining well so it's also
you know even when I and this has
happened to me repeatedly you know
because I've interviewed a lot of people
who've been pilloried and canceled
you know and
when I I was Ill a while back and when I
sort of re-emerged into the podcast
sphere after a couple of years the first
person I interviewed was Abigail
schreier and she'd just written a book
called irreversible damage about this
absolutely god-awful catastrophe on the
transfront that Physicians and
psychologists are collaborating and
producing and uh much to our shame let's
say and uh
I know Abigail had been pilloried by all
The Usual Suspects and and tarred and
feathered and and uh with the with the
brush of disgust and contempt and you
know even though I've been through this
and known many people who've been
through it every time I pick another one
of the deplorable people to interview
like you
there's a part of me that goes along
with that
unthinking mob mentality
such that once the accusation has been
made
I'm forced to confront my suspicion that
well where there's smoke there must be
fire you know that well Dr Jensen I mean
you haven't been investigated just once
and not even twice you've been
investigated what is it seven times now
six times is it is it seven six six and
so you're really telling me that
you're in you're guilty of all charges
in six separate investigations over
multiple years well it's a hell of a lot
easier to believe that no you know even
though
maybe you're technically innocent on
some of the charges there's something
you're up to and it's easy to put you in
the basket of people who
shouldn't be validated at least
and you know it's partly because there's
a lot of people and
if anyone is
disgraced
it's easy to put them in the basket of
people you shouldn't interact with and
and that means this accusatory power
that we've put in the hands of anonymous
trolls
uh
and allowing them to take the grip of
the of the controls of boards with as
much power as the Minnesota Board of
medical practice is uh what it's a it's
a power that's
extraordinarily
deep and far-reaching
and can easily destroy people's lives
and there's something that's
truly awful about that and it's not
surprising that people move away from
you once you've been tarred by that
brush
during the course of the campaign
a large thrust of my opponent's strategy
was to paint me as extreme
and you're spotlighting that exactly
correctly I think that human nature is
such that when something adverse happens
to someone else
the human mind looks for some
justification well that person maybe did
this or maybe that person could have
done this and didn't or maybe that
person had it coming and that kind of
underlying
subconscious
part of all of us does color the way we
look at that person so I had that well
we'll even do that to ourselves we do we
do it to our loved ones we do it to
friends we we look for that
justification because when we find it or
if we can conjure it up then we can say
that's why it didn't happen to me
and so when I was running for governor I
think there was a tremendous skepticism
thrown around my character
could that have been determining in
terms of the outcome absolutely one of
the things I've heard from people after
the governor's race was they said doc
the real you never got transmitted to
the everyday masses of Voters who never
had a chance to meet you they don't
really know who you are they see you as
this demonized villain that the
Democrats had said he's a part of the
big lie and I think you're absolutely
right human nature is to look for the
justification as to why someone else is
suffering and you're not and generally
there'll be some overhanging residue
that even as we try to thoughtfully look
at the situation
we cannot Escape that residual well
maybe he or she had it coming
yeah yeah in some manner yeah yeah well
it's an it's an easy default position
it's very difficult to fight over that
and to well that's why the presumption
of innocence
in the legal systems in civilized
countries is such a complete bloody
Miracle because
I also noticed as a clinician you know
that I was often dealing with people who
had been accused in one way or another
Often by themselves of some malfeasance
and I always took the case that my role
as a counselor was to begin with the
presumption of innocence and to
investigate based on that presumption
but also to help my client
even in regards to themselves to start
with the presumption of innocence so if
someone was feeling very guilty and was
depressed for example which is a very
that's a situation where the adversary
is within and is eating you eating your
soul so to speak you have to mount a
strong defense and you know that means
that you should
take a very careful look at your
weaknesses and your transgressions but
you should do that from the presumption
from the initial presumption of
innocence
and so and that's a hard thing to learn
too when you're being prosecuted in the
manner that you've been prosecuted
because in order to withstand that
without falling prey to the trauma
associated with derealization
you have to get your ducks in order so
that you can justify to yourself your
own claims of Innocence
and that means you also have to learn to
do that with a without a kind of
careless self-righteousness and also
without that proclivity to move toward
more extreme views which does also lurk
as a Temptation under such circumstances
I recall vividly
when I used to do work with chemical
dependency patients one of the steps of
the AAA Alcoholics Anonymous was to take
that ruthless inventory
of ourselves
and I think
you're absolutely right that ability to
take a ruthless inventory of your
shortcomings
comes in conflict with the need to
presume that you yourself are innocent
so oftentimes the guilt is deep it's
hard to remove and I think when I went
through the trauma of my 30 year old
brother committing suicide
one of the things that troubled me most
in the aftermath was that as a physician
I wasn't evidently able to help him
navigate a path through that
guilt
inventory kind of process that his life
was taking him on and so in the end
some element of justification within him
said
it's okay for me to end this because
I'm not making my way and the world
would be better I would be better not
here and I'll never forget that that
that that indeed is the case that we
don't always presume that we're innocent
we're doing that ruthless inventory even
if we want to cut ourselves some slack
it's tough
yeah yeah it's a very it's a very and
that's that's especially I would say
true again for a conscientious person
because you're going to take yourself
there's going to be a tendency to take
yourself to task very harshly and that
can easily be weaponized by people who
don't have that proclivity and would
like to use it against you the woke
guilt-mongering left have become
absolutely expert at this yeah much to
the Chagrin in danger of competent and
hard-working people everywhere okay so
now you're in your fifth set of
Investigations with 18 allegations in
the middle of a gubernatorial race and
despite the fact that there's 18
they're all dismissed
and yet
they investigate you a sixth time
so let's go to the sixth time
the fifth investigation started in
November of 2021 and was literally put
on hold during the course of the
campaign so that was present for about
12 months of the campaign
when it was resurrected in January of
this year
a sixth investigation was initiated with
additional allegations being put forward
that was literally combined into a fifth
and sixth investigation together which
culminated in our meeting last week with
the Minnesota Board of medical practice
and it was at that meeting where the
fifth and sixth combined investigations
with its commensurate 18 allegations
were completely dismissed
it was very brief the letter I just
received a couple of days ago was these
allegations have all been dismissed this
case is closed
okay so let me ask you some questions
about that so now how many allegations
in total
do you suppose have been levied against
you by the Minnesota Board of Medical
Practice
it was difficult to tell it they've said
yeah there were eight yeah because one
two three four five and six and it
seemed that with the sixth investigative
letter they were
dredging up
allegations that had already been
addressed and dismissed
so as I read through the document it
says there's 18 allegations I could find
nine real clearly then I could find some
other
comments that may have represented an
allegation but I never saw a list of
these are the 18 allegations that Dr
Jensen has been accused of so it was a
little so that makes the kafka-esque
nightmare perfect because now you don't
even know what precisely it is that
you're accused of that makes defense a
lot more difficult
so I said that afterwards that's the
point
during our conference I was asked
something about a conspiracy theory and
I said could I please know what
conspiracy theory I am purported to have
advanced someone would ask me a question
about
an off-label medication and I can say
can I please know which medication we're
talking about someone would say that
well your writing wasn't very legible on
this chart note
can you please show me which word you
couldn't read
it was extremely difficult and in fact
during the course of the conference I
did at one point in time say this feels
like goulash
I don't know what to respond to because
the generalities are so vague how can I
possibly know what you want me to say I
said I've given thousands and thousands
of speeches comments on the senate floor
during the campaign in podcasts on
videos and someone says you did this
show me
just show me
perhaps one of the most compelling
things I did at the end of the board of
Medical Practice conference I looked at
my accusers
and I just
sort of shrug my shoulders and I said
I did nothing wrong
and I stopped
why do you think that was effective
well my attorney was nervous about it
because he felt that the tenor of the
meeting was moving towards a desire to
resolve the issue and not have it be
disagreeable or contentious and when I
made that comment he told me later on he
said Scott he said you made me Flinch I
was concerned that that was going to be
to bold a statement to in your face I
did nothing wrong but he said I think it
worked out perfectly because I think it
did give the board of Medical Practice
members a clear sense that
I do care about the standard of care I
do care about not doing things wrong and
I don't think I did anything wrong
earlier in the meeting I had made the
challenge to the board I said I think
it's critically important that people
understand the difference between
misinformation and disinformation I said
disinformation is the deliberate attempt
to mislead with false or deceptive
information misinformation is simply
someone's truth on a Monday being
demonstrated on a Friday that it's not
the situation
well I think that
the terms misinformation and
disinformation
are unerring markers that the person who
is using them has already become
entirely confused about what constitutes
the manner in which the world operates
I mean first of all
who's to say who's wrong about what when
the issues are contentious
there's not some board of overseers that
has unerring insight into what
constitutes the appropriate facts about
hand the world would be a very
straightforward place if it was that
simple and I've seen the rise of these
terms misinformation and disinformation
over the last two or three years and
watched that with Dawning horror because
the whole semantic substructure of that
classification system is based on the
presupposition that the dividing line
between fact and fiction or fact fiction
and lie is obvious to anyone with the
proper objective stance and uh the
question is always begged well just who
is this wizard that can see so clearly
through all the Merck
especially not post Hawk and as soon as
you even allow those terms to exist
misinformation and disinformation you're
already going to find yourself in an
extraordinarily dark place
and so
so um
do you think
have you received anything approximating
an apology and do you think that
or a hint of culpability on the part of
the people who are Sitting on This
board and do you think that
there's any chance that they'll leave
you alone
I've not received any kind of apologetic
Overture from the board and I don't
expect to I believe that those members
believe that they are carrying out the
mission of their regulatory agency to
the best of their ability
as you indicated earlier
oftentimes why do you believe that look
man they've gone after you
look if they'd gone after you once and
you defended yourself
and then they came after you again and
you defended yourself and that was all
cleared up I would say hey
they might have been a little on
overzealous side but twice that's within
the realm of
forgivable willful brought blindness
three times that's a pattern
six times that's not a pattern
that's absolute 100 proof and so if
they're still believing that what they
were doing was
um undertaking their sworn duties as
appropriately behaving members of the
Minnesota Board of Medical Practice they
have their heads in the sound because
six man
six is too many three is too many
but six is definitely too many
so that's why I was wondering also about
any nature of public statement because
you would presume if you still thought
you were in the domain of the vaguely
rational that what the Minnesota Board
of Medical Practice would do would put
out a press release saying
Dr Jensen has been the subject of
numerous investigations now extending
over numerous years including a variety
of allegations
some uncountable number apparently but
let's say 18. he has demonstrated his
innocence in all cases and we would like
to ensure that everyone knows that and
the case is closed now that's minimally
professionally responsible as far as I'm
concerned minimally because you've been
dragged through quite a lovely form of
hell maybe you lost an election because
of it and you know in some sense that's
too bad for you but in a much deeper
sense that's too bad for the citizens of
Minnesota whose electoral process was
hijacked by an inappropriate
investigation and that's not forgivable
and as far as I'm concerned that's on
them
and so I don't think that it's
reasonable to presume that after the
sixth failed investigation especially in
a high-stakes situation like this that
what the board members were doing was
just within the realm of their uh
appropriate would what would you say
domain of professional responsibility
it's like three times guys you're
pushing it six times you're Way Beyond
The Pale especially when there's as much
political
context muddying up the circumstance as
there is in your specific case
so I would love to I would love to
receive a letter as you just mentioned
but I think that through this process I
perhaps moved a little bit from a naive
Optimist into somewhat more of a cynic
when it comes to Regulatory Agencies I
think that what I went through is
something that virtually anybody could
go through if it happened to me it could
happen to you if you're subject to any
regulatory agency I don't care if you
own a hair salon a restaurant a pub a
dental clinic if you're subject to a
regulatory agency what we have seen is
they are able to be weaponized the board
of Medical Practice does not believe
that they were weaponized I indicated to
them I don't think the individuals were
but I think the agency collectively was
I think that frankly how did they
justify their claim that they weren't
weaponized how in the world could they
be wrong 18 times
18 is a lot of times to be wrong
you know that's a pattern too so how
would how did they claim that they
weren't weaponized
I think there's an underlying sense
within many regulatory agencies and
perhaps the Minnesota Board of medical
practice is one
is that as you said earlier anybody that
has 18 allegations against him there's
got to be some element of
he should be discredited and during the
course of our meeting
there was a point in time where I was
uncomfortable where I said
are you going to discredit anybody that
doesn't perceive the situation as
yourself and I mentioned people like Dr
Peter McCullough and Dr budhachara and
Dr Harvey Rish and there was an absolute
willingness to dismiss those people as
either
discredited and irrelevant or whatever I
mean I remember that was not the number
no one less credible than Jay
bhattacharya after all I mean all you
have to do is look at his record as an
academic to understand very deeply how
much credibility he Lacks
I was proud of the fact that I believe I
was one of the first Physicians to sign
on to the Great Barrington declaration
way back in 2020 I believe it was I
thought that it was a brilliant document
identifying the strengths and weaknesses
of what public health could do the
lockdowns weren't working the locking in
of the nursing home patients to die
horrific lonely deaths the Locking out
of students all of this was problematic
at a deep level
so when we saw this document come out
and say listen
we know where this virus wants to hit we
know who's particularly vulnerable let's
provide laser focused protection for
those people and recognize that we have
an economy to maintain we have a mental
health responsibility we cannot damage
our children for decades to come and yet
all of that was thrown aside in part
because there's this contest going on
where my experts are more important than
yours my Champions are more soundly
rational than yours there's this
constant so with the great Barry with
the Great Barrington declaration which
is something that badacheria initiated
we now have a total signature volume of
a million people it's 936
000.
um
47 000 of those are medical
practitioners
so when you go in front of the Minnesota
Board of medical
practice you can say well
47 000 medical practitioners worldwide
tend to agree that my misinformation was
accurate
and so on what grounds do you stand and
the answer is well the answer I get from
places like the Ontario colleges
psychologists is we don't have to answer
questions like that which is so at the
moment I'm as you know I'm in a
situation that's pretty similar to yours
although
it didn't destroy my political career it
certainly did in my clinical career
that's for sure much to the Chagrin and
damage of my clients by the way some of
whom might had ref
what
uh
I had a relationship with that spanned
years and sometimes decades which all
burned up in an instant and uh
they're hauling me in front of their
they've threatened to haul me in front
of an interview because I told them to
go to hell with their insistence that
I'd be re-educated
interminably by their experts according
to their standards for a duration they
choose
and so now I'm supposed to face the same
sort of in-person Examining Board that
just grilled you over the coals but
they're delaying and delaying and
delaying because
well
why not I suppose I think they're
suffering from the extreme delusion that
if they leave this Hornet's Nest alone
uh the Hornets will leave but that's
definitely not going to happen so I've
been calling on them publicly in Canada
rather repeatedly to get on with the
Inquisition but um
at the moment they're hiding behind a
variety of bureaucratic idiocies
to make the case that they have the
right to delay the investigation beyond
the
statutory limitations for it that
they've even imposed upon themselves
right because there's a 150 day period
within which if I understand correctly
within which these are supposed to be
you know brought to something
approximating a conclusion once they've
been initiated so that you're not hung
out to dry forever but you know there's
always a reason for bureaucrats to get
around their own bureaucratic
limitations and that's certainly
happening in the Canadian situation but
um did they give you
the sense that
you better continue to step lightly Dr
Jensen because with your reprehensible
history of six investigations it's only
a matter of time until you say something
else cataclysmically inappropriate and
we haul you in front of ourselves again
or do you think maybe they've gone back
into their uh layer to
find someone else to torment
I think there was a clear understanding
that there were a couple things that
were really problematic for them and
that if I
would once again engage in that kind of
activity
I would very likely appear before them
again I think specifically so what what
would those be yeah I think specifically
utilizing off-label medications
for the treatment of Physicians do that
all the time Physicians do that all the
time
I pointed that out to them I pointed
that out that many pediatricians would
have more than 50 percent of their
prescriptions would be off label but
specifically the off-label use of
ivermectin was very problematic for them
and and how dangerous is Ivermectin if
you look at the various reports
if you look at the history of the
medication the FDA data and the varis
data I think ivermectin for a five-day
course is extremely safe now whether or
not looks like it's about as safe as
water right I don't I don't think you I
think you'd have to scour the medical
literature long and hard before you
found a drug with as low a proportion of
side effects to benefit as ivermected
there's been millions of doses given and
the cytop side effect reporting is so
remarkably low that it's a kind of
Miracle so if you're gonna
administer
agent off label it's hard for me to see
how you could do something that would
bring about less likely harm than
ivermected do you think that's a
reasonable position
I think ivermecta is very safe I think a
lot of people don't realize that it's
available over the counter in topical
forms I think there's a medicine called
sklice that people could purchase on
their own but I think that the board of
Medical Practice made it clear that this
was a big deal I think they also made it
very clear that what they perceive the
standard of care to be they often talked
about the minimum standard of care they
asked me what do you think the minimum
standard of care is and I said I've
never really thought about the minimum
standard of care because that's never
what I've aspired to provide I've always
thought that I wanted to provide the
best quality of care and I think that
that's what I've done so
in terms of going forward
your question is extremely pertinent is
there going to be a seventh
investigation
is someone from the public gonna say
we're going to keep making Dr Scott
Jensen's life a living hell until he
shuts up
I'm going to guess that's going to
happen that's why I keep coming back to
the point
we do not have a clearly defined line
that we need to have
between my rights a First Amendment
speech and the Minnesota boards
obligation to make certain that my
professional conduct as it pertains to
the practice of medicine is above the
minimum standard of care to me that's
what needs to happen yet and so I don't
think
we could possibly be done with this
issue in America I think we we need the
courts to weigh in and say listen if
states have put together statute
language that violates the Constitution
it's unconstitutional if
regulatory agencies are stepping beyond
their bounds thinking that they get to
do this and this and this and it's
unconstitutional it needs to be declared
that because if there's one thing that
covid-19 has done it has put a spotlight
on regulatory agencies that can go after
you me the hair salon person the pub
owner the restaurant Runner
everybody we are all at risk frankly Dr
Peterson that's why I wrote my book
we've been played because I said we need
to make certain we're seeing what's
going on in our world the world of big
Tech and big Pharma and big government
colluding and having a similar Mission
it's happening right in front of our
eyes and I'm saying that people like you
and me we have an obligation to expose
that we saw big government protect big
Pharma we saw big Pharma in big Tech
scratching each other's back we saw the
dod in the United States provided more
money to Pfizer in 2022 than they did to
Boeing the Department of Defense spends
more money paying Pfizer than they spend
Boeing which is going to make
weaponry and aircraft that will protect
our nation we've gone upside down and we
need to stop this
well
Dr Jensen that's a pretty good place to
end I would say yeah well and for all of
you professionals who are listening
you're living in a Fool's Paradise if
you don't think this is coming down the
Pikes for you and what do I mean by that
it's like
you know you might not be investigated
although I wouldn't
rule that out I would say
if I was advising a young professional
now I would say you better make the
presumption and prepare for the
likelihood that at some point
someone
with the with the delightful intrinsic
nature of an Eastern European KGB
Informer of the
1970s is gonna Target you for some
resentful reason and the board of
regular Regulators Regulators of your
profession is going to make your life
hell so you better bloody well prepare
for that for that because that's coming
along but I would also say that even if
you're not unfortunate enough to have
that happen and you will be but even if
you're not
you're in a situation now whereas a
licensed professional
you're gonna have to live in a certain
amount of fear with regards to the
freedom of your tongue and that's going
to make you much less
secure and happy person publicly is
going to make you a much worse
professional
because if you can no longer say what
you think as a professional with the
attendant risk of being wrong you're no
longer of any use to your patients or
clients or
or customers and so that's a pretty damn
dismal outcome the right outcome here is
for the
weaponized Boards of
regulatory practice to be scuttled
because they've been corrupted Beyond
repair
they've been weaponized partly by easy
access to the complaint process
electronically they've failed to update
themselves with the times they put all
the hands in the power of idiot vengeful
accusers and uh
they pose a far greater threat to the
public than they do a defense
and the re and the legislators who are
listening especially on the Republican
side the more conservative side should
wake up and understand that this is a
catastrophe because it's not just Dr
Jensen it's all Physicians it's all
psychologists it's all teachers it's all
lawyers even more ominously because the
equivalent boards that regulate legal
practice are perhaps even worse and
that's really saying something and so
um we're not in Kansas anymore and it's
not 1947 with Jimmy Stewart I don't know
where the hell we are but that's not it
and uh all of you professionals who are
listening you
it would be better for you in the medium
and long run that you wake up and smell
the coffee and that when someone like Dr
Jensen with his Stellar record is being
attacked by your idiot Boards of
Regulation that silence is not in your
best interest
and so well one of the things that I've
shared with many audiences is I've said
the words of Martin niemoller in the
mid-1940s when he wrote when they came
for the trade unionists I didn't speak
up because I wasn't a trade unionist
when they came for the Communists I
didn't speak up because I wasn't a
communist when they came for the Jews I
didn't speak up because I wasn't a Jew
and when they came for me there was
nobody left to speak up
I don't know that there's any essay or
poem written that could be more
compelling than that is we have to speak
up we have to stand at your side we have
to stand at my side we have to recognize
that we're not in Kansas anymore that we
should not be threatened with the idea
of being sent to a re-education camp
simply because we express our heartfelt
perspective on a given situation
Amen to that so well
we'll see how the college Inquisition in
Ontario
rolls itself out they
came after me with 13 allegations in the
last round and uh
you know I mounted my defense which has
been an extraordinarily expensive
undertaking and has all the complexities
that you described but they seem to be
at a little bit of a stalemate at the
moment in relationship to their
continued persecution and as far as I'm
concerned this is a No Holds Barred
all-out war and so I'm actually looking
forward to being brought in front of the
disciplinary committee because as I
understand it they videotape it and I'm
going to put the videotape on YouTube
after I'm done and uh we'll see who
inquires into the conduct of who
so Dr Peterson to that point
when i s when the Minnesota Board of
Medical Practice introduced themselves
at our meeting last week
they advised me that it was going to be
recorded so I asked if I could have a
copy of the recording and I was told I
would not be able to have a copy of the
recording unless our proceedings
Advanced along a pathway whereby
legal statute would allow me to have a
copy but otherwise I would not have a
copy of that and I thought that was
interesting I thought that it was
interesting that they were going to
record it I would not get a copy unless
potentially we went to another step
where I would formally and make a legal
request for that so I did find that
interesting as well
yeah yeah well it should be the case
that these it's it's necessarily it's
necessary now for these to be these
especially the final stages of these
inquisitions to be a matter of public
record and in my case one way or another
they're going to be a matter of public
record
so I requested that any more meeting
I requested that our meeting not be Zoom
I wanted it face to face I wanted it
Facebook live streamed and I wanted it
open to the public and I wanted to copy
the recording and the only one I got was
I did get a face-to-face meeting
right right right well congratulations
on your newfound Freedom so to speak
um
it's it's good to see that you've
managed to come through this
more or less intact and that you're not
you know down for the count because
plenty of people
I've really been struck to my soul I
would say watching
what this has done to people the people
that I've encountered who've been
dragged through the mud in this manner
it's uh there's almost nothing you can
do to someone who's
strived hard to put forward a credible
professional career and made the
sacrifices necessary to ensure that that
occurs than to denigrate their
reputation and to accuse them of
professional malfeasance it's an
unbelievably effective weapon and when
wielded properly it reeks tremendous
havoc on people's lives of course
including the lives of the people who
are being served by that professional
um
upon whose reputation at minimum of Paul
has now been cast and faith
what shaken even under the best
circumstances and so it's good to see
that you're bloody but unbowed so to
speak and I hope the bastards leave you
the hell alone from here on in but they
probably won't
so
forearmed is for what is it forewarned
is forearmed and so I guess you've been
through this enough now to know what to
do the next time that the snake comes
around to inject some more Venom
good talking to you today sir
thank you I appreciate it very much I do
yeah
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com